he's how important is Hollywood
nightlife and networking and parties to
an acting career where is it the waste
of time just an excuse to nightlife um I
think it's very important I mean you
know networking is yeah you know this
town I mean it's it's not just a cliche
saying right who you know like I mean
that that does you know carry weight big
time you know um you know yeah I think
it's important I've taken a few like
networking classes you know there's tons
of them in the city um and I think it's
important to be able to go out and just
meet people you know it's a very fine
line you know and like for me I was
always like I don't want to be that guy
you know like I just I don't feel
comfortable with that like I'm very
personable but like in a town when
people know like you know everyone out
there is trying to find out who each
other is like there's a weird pressure
there you know so it's like I feel like
everybody's already expecting that and
like as genuine as I may be to really
like try to engage and talk to somebody
I sometimes was put off by the fact that
like no but they're gonna think I'm just
talking and try to find out who they are
or what they do you know and and like
that's not you know i don't i don't like
that pressure but sometimes it's just
put on you know it's just my own you
know sort of pressure that I put on
myself but um you know I think I think
it's very important you know and I have
tons of friends who are like I'm
shooting this new movie because I met
this person that you know bar louie or
whatever it was you know so there are
all these you know instances where you
meet people my friend is in town from
canada now and she met david o russell i
forget where she met that him and then
they were just just struck up a
conversation he brought her in to
audition for this new movie that he's
doing you know so it's like yeah those
things happen you know so I think it's
really key to find that fine line and
not you know just be at places and
thanks for that you know i mean it's
it's obviously a part of it and and you
know there are times where you people
just show up to the things all the time
and then you just see the same people
all the time as
you know make it its timing right like
it's make make your time worth while you
know and sometimes I feel like if people
are doing all the same things all the
time like then you know I don't know you
you've done it already you know I mean
you've done it find a new way to sort of
you know market yourself or whatever it
is and I think that that's important too
to sort of know that like you're
spending your time the right way you
know what I mean and and sometimes being
out there and grabbing a drink and and
and maybe meeting somebody is great but
like also going home and rehearsing a
monologue or something or working on
your craft is also just a strong
you